-The Lesson Page-
The Lesson page is split into two parts. In the Dashboard on the right you can find a variety of information about the lesson. You can listen to the audio, and keep track of your activity.
The blue New Words tab displays all of the new words in the lesson. The yellow LingQs tab shows all of your saved words in the lesson.
In the Info tab you can follow the growth of your Avatar. You can also see statistics related to each lesson.
You can minimize the dashboard by clicking the button at the top right. This makes it easier to review lessons when using a smaller screen.
On the left hand side you will find the lesson text. New words are shown in blue. If you encounter a new word, just click on it.
You can select one of the Hints that are displayed and save it. If you prefer you can click on Search Dictionary to find a new definition in the dictionary.
Once a word is saved it will turn yellow. We call this creating a ?LingQ?. If you already know a word, you may want to click "Known?" to add it to your Known Words total.
You can also leave new words blue and convert all remaining words to "Known?" at the bottom of the lesson page.
-Vocabulary-
All the LingQs you have created are found in the Vocabulary section.
In the Vocabulary section you can review your LingQs using a variety of vocabulary review tests. You can also edit LingQs and adjust their status.
Each day you will be sent a list of LingQs to review, in what is called the "LingQs of the Day" email.
-Mobile Apps-
If you have an iOS or Android device, you can use our iLingQ app. The app allows you to study flashcards, review your lessons and create playlists to listen to on the go.
To download the app, click on the icon at the bottom of the page.